Here is my code.
I compute the dx and dy the way I told you by using the spath of index i + 1
minus the same at index.
My rx and ry, called drx and dry over here, are the robot estimates
as obtained by the filter minus the path.
Then I apply the exact same two equations that I gave you for the progress U
and the crosstrack error cte as shown over here.
Of course, if I advance too much I add 1 to the index.
You could have done this before computing the crosstrack error,
but I chose to do it afterwards.
So I add the missing bracket, and when I run it I get sometimes a collision.
There are two collisions here but I still reach the goal in 140 steps.
Let me run it again, and now I reach the goal without collision.